nobody's ever got my name Brendan Fraser
see it didn't sound right it felt good
though Brendan Fraser and Adam Sandler
had an epic reunion for variety's new
actors on actors issue while looking
back on working together on the 1994
comedy AirHeads Adam revealed that
Brendan almost wasn't cast as singer
Chaz Darby but Brandon you were in a
movie called AirHeads remember when I
discovered you got my Rhythm Section
inside keeping an eye on me it's fine
Nobody's Gonna Hurt You Michael Lehman
was very against you he was like I don't
get it I don't see the caveman being in
this movie and I just said he can do
others people in my chain right now I
eventually went to his house like four
in the morning woke him up and he's like
who are you I said never mind that but
just know that Adam Sandler ain't gonna
be in Airheads unless all crazier is in
it he didn't want you I did and the rest
is uh pretty good you had a good life
possible yeah way to go meanwhile
Brendan also recalled how starring in
1997's George of the Jungle left him so
starved for carbohydrates that he forgot
his own ATM code you went on first of
all to leave AirHeads and then get very
jacked for George in the jungle I was
disappointed how good you look
George George of the Jungle
waxed at least
starved in carbohydrates like we'd drive
home after work and stop to get
something to eat and I needed some cash
one day and I went to the ATM and I
could not remember my PIN number of the
frame is Miss Byron